[Music]
new Harry Potter film JK Rowling teases
sequel in cryptic tweet calm down I hope
you're all doing well it is of course
your lucky day and that's because I've
done it again I've made a video I know
you're excited it's been three days
since the last one she might have been
four you've probably barely been
scraping by in this video I'm going to
be discussing JK Rowling and the rumors
surrounding a potential new Harry Potter
film without ruining too much too soon
try to calm down seriously calm down
because the rumors really aren't quite
what they seem on September 5th Rowling
tweeted sometimes darkness comes from
unexpected places
hashtag Harry Potter hashtag curse into
child now this may seem exciting but in
reality it is of course typical of
rolling to tweet overly cryptic
gibberish you may be thinking the
courser child came out three years ago
what's the significance of this tweet
and you wouldn't be alone in thinking
that that wasn't a unique thought at all
what many derived from this tweet was
that perhaps there could be a new Harry
Potter sequel in works or perhaps even a
film adaptation of the cursed child
naturally annoyingly overeager fans
started these rumors however it quickly
became apparent that people got a little
too excited a little too early because
the claims were shut down by Broadway
representatives
shortly after in a statement released
they said I can confirm that these
rumors are absolutely not true the show
has not changed ownership Harry Potter
and the cursed child continues to be
produced by Sonya Freedman Colin
calendar and Harry Potter theatrical
productions in London Broadway and all
around the world Warner Brothers has
always been a valued partner of coaster
Charles since its inception their role
has not changed two years ago Rowling
tweeted remarking I know a lot of people
looking for reasons to be cheerful today
but there is no to
truth to the rumor about a cursed child
movie trilogy perfect following up with
fans once more Pottermore tweeted there
is something exciting coming later on
from cursor child NYC but it's not a
movie
now these tweets are actually released
two days ago and the mystery has been
since unraveled the tweets are actually
in reference to the cursed child Time
Square takeover in New York where Time
Square blew up with cursor child media
in short the news is definitely less
exciting than a movie JK Rowling tweeted
more nothing and my Harry Potter channel
is spectacular